konnte zwischen den fraktionen keine
tagesordnung vereinbart werden die
fraktion der fdp hat den vorschlag der
anderen fraktionen widersprochen
nach dem bundestag also mit der
vorgeschlagene tagen einberufen und nach
§ 21 absatz 3 der geschäftsordnung ist
für die genehmigung der tagesordnung
beschluss erforderlich
in der fraktion ist vereinbart worden
die noch zu beschließende tagesordnung
um die in der zusatzpunkte liste
aufgeführten punkte zu erweitern
von der frist für den beginn der
beratungen soll soweit erforderlich
abgewichen werden
nach der fragestunde wird soll eine
vereinbare debatte zum thema deutscher
ratspräsidentschaft mit ganzer kraft
europa stark mal und stattfinden
im einzel seine tagesordnungspunkt 7
soll die erste beratung des entwurfs
eines gesetzes zur verbesserung des
verbraucherschutzes im inkasso recht und
zur änderung weiterer vorschriften auf
der drucksache 2003 48 mit einer
debatten zeit von 30 minuten aufgesetzt
werden im anschluss seine
tagesordnungspunkt 9
weil die zweite und dritte beratung des
entwurfs eines grundrente gesetzes auf
der drucksache 18 473 mit einer debatten
zeit von 60 minuten stattfinden
die tagesordnungspunkte zehn und zwölf
verschieben sich entsprechend nach
hinten für den tagesordnungspunkt 10
reduziert sich dadurch die debatten zeit
von 60 auf 30 minuten um 1 ist ein
tagesordnungspunkt 31 sondern wahlen von
mitgliedern folgender gremien aufgerufen
werden kuratorium der stiftung
erinnerung verantwortung und zukunft
stiftungsrat der stiftung flucht
vertreibung und versöhnung sowie
stiftungsrat der stiftung zur
aufarbeitung der sed diktatur
danach soll auf verlangen der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen eine aktuelle
stunde zu dem thema der fall wirecard
versagen von aufsicht und
wirtschaftsprüfung aufklärend
durchgeführt werden
die mainzer seine tagesordnungspunkt 12
soll der antrag urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zum
anleihekaufprogramm psp europäischen
zentralbank mit einer debatten dauer von
30 minuten beraten werden
die nachfolgenden tagesordnungspunkte
der koalition verschieben sich
entsprechend nach hinten
nach dem tagesordnungspunkt 19 die
zweite und dritte rate des entwurfs
eines gesetzes zur änderung des
strafgesetzbuchs verbesserung des
persönlichkeitsschutzes bei
bildaufnahmen auf der drucksache 17 795
debatten dauer von 30 minuten
stattfinden
der tagesordnungspunkt 20b soll ohne
debatte in verbindung mit dem
tagesordnungspunkt 30 aufgerufen werden
der tagesordnungspunkt 21 soll nach
tages auf nun 28 beraten werden die
tagesordnungspunkte 8 r sowie 30 eu und
z soll abgesetzt werden
schließlich mache ich sie noch auf die
im anhang zur zusatzpunkte liste
aufgeführten nachträglichen
überweisungen aufmerksam
außerdem soll die stellungnahme des
bundesrats zum zweiten
nachtragshaushaltsgesetz 2020 auf der
drucksache 20.000 0 1 in den
haushaltsausschuss überwiesen werden
und nach all dem kommen wir jetzt
feststellen der tagesordnungen der 169
1770 971 sitzungen mit den genannten
änderungen und ergänzungen wer stimmt
für diese tagesordnung wer sind dagegen
wäre enthält sich dann ist die
tagesordnung gegen die stimmen der afd
mit den stimmen des übrigen hauses
angenommen
und jetzt hoffe ich auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 2 die befragung der
bundesregierung die bundesregierung hat
mitgeteilt dass heute die
bundeskanzlerin frau dr
mehr zur verfügung stehen sie haben das
wort
ja liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
natürlich vor allen dingen die sehr
geehrter herr präsident ich möchte in
meinen einführenden worten heute dass
der erste juli ist und die deutsche rats
präsidentschaft beginnt dazu stellung
nehmen
heute übernimmt deutschland in einer
schwierigen zeit für ein halbes jahr den
vorsitz im rat der europäischen union
und natürlich wird unsere harz
präsidentschaft von der korona virus
pandemie den bemühungen zu ihrer
eindämmung und der bewältigung ihrer
folgen geprägt sein
ich habe sie vor zwei wochen hier an
dieser stelle um unterstützung für den
beispiellosen aufbauplan gebieten mit
denen wir die wirtschaftliche und
soziale erholung in europa gemeinsam
angehen wollen
der europäische rat hat sich vor zwei
wochen erstmals damit befasst und wir
waren uns einig dass wir in einer
außergewöhnlichen situation auch
lösungen brauchen die besonders sind
damit europa stark aus dieser
außergewöhnlichen krise hervorgehen kann
ich muss ihnen sagen dass die positionen
der mitgliedstaaten noch weit
auseinanderliegen der präsident des
europäischen rates schon michelle hat
für den 17 juli zur erneuten beratung
eingeladen und zur vorbereitung werden
noch viele gespräche notwendig seien bei
dem wir und in diesem falle ich auch als
rotierende ratspräsidentschaft dem
ratspräsidenten eng zur seite stehen
werde
ich unterstütze ihn eigens also dabei
eine zügige einigung zu erreichen damit
die wirtschaftliche erholung auch
wirklich rechtzeitig und nachhaltig
möglich ist besonders wichtig ist mir
dass die wirtschaftliche erholung allen
zugute kommt und wir nicht nur
beschäftigung einkommen und unternehmen
sichern sondern ganz besonders auch den
zusammenhalt in europa stärken dazu
gehört auch dass die chancen der jungen
menschen in europa zu sichern sind und
wir setzen uns deshalb in unserer
ratspräsidentschaft auch für die
stärkung der sogenannten jugend garantie
also die möglichkeit für jeden jungen
menschen auch arbeit zu bekommen ein
doch in den kommenden sechs monaten
werden wir nicht alle in die
krisenbewältigung vorantreiben sondern
auch intensiv daran arbeiten wir
den schlüsselfragen klimaschutz
digitales souveränität und europas rolle
in der welt zukunft gestalten können
das habe ich auch vor zwei wochen
ausführlich dargelegt und heute möchte
ich noch auf eine weitere
herausforderung unserer rats
präsidentschaft hinweisen nämlich auf
die frage des künftigen verhältnisses
der europäischen union zum vereinigten
königreich die fortschritte in den
verhandlungen sind hier um es
zurückhaltend zu formulieren sehr
übersichtlich wir haben mit
großbritannien vereinbart jetzt diese
verhandlungen zu beschleunigen um im
herbst noch ein abkommen zu beschließen
das dann ja auch bis zum ende des jahres
ratifiziert werden müsste
ich werde mich weiterhin für eine gute
lösung stark machen
aber wir müssen und sollten in der eu
und auch in deutschland für den fall
vorsorgen dass ein abkommen doch nicht
zustande kommt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ihre erwartungen an die
deutsche präsidentschaft sind hoch und
ich darf im namen der ganzen
bundesregierung sagen dass wir
entschlossen sind alles dafür zu tun
dass wir als europäerinnen und europäer
gemeinsam vorankommen in und für europa
und mit unseren internationalen partnern
und dabei bitte ich sie auch in ihren
kontakten zu den parlamenten in den
mitgliedstaaten für die ziele der
deutschen ratspräsidentschaft zu werben
denn nur mit denen und mit der
unterstützung aus den nationalen
parlamenten aller mitgliedstaaten werden
wir die großen herausforderungen auch
bewältigen können lassen sie uns also
das motto unserer ratspräsidentschaft
mit leben erfüllen gemeinsam europa
wieder stark machen
herzlichen dank
damit kommen wir zur befragung und die
erste frage gestellt der kollege dr
gutfried curio fdp-frau kanzlerin die
taz druckte wenige tage vor den
gewaltexzessen in stuttgart polizisten
gehörten auf den abfall da seien sie
unter ihresgleichen
diese volksverhetzung verletzung der
menschenwürde und angriff auf die
ordnungsmacht des staates wollten sie
nicht vom innenminister rechtlich
überprüft sehen
der verantwortliche dienstherr selbst
sollte sich nicht vor seine leute
stellen
sie wollten er die verunglimpfung
freiheit der links besser geschützt
sehen meinten gar derartiges sei wohl
legitime meinungsäußerung ist ihnen klar
dass sie den minister genau an dem
hindern
wofür sie ein netz gesetz gemacht haben
wird de facto zur zensur normaler freie
meinungsäußerung gebraucht wird wendt
bei der taz wirkliche hassrede zu
unterbinden gewesen wäre
sie verhindern hier ein politisches
zeichen gegen die die unsere
sicherheitskräfte hinterrücks in den
rücken treten ich frage sie wie kommen
sie dazu einen innenminister abzuhalten
der diese hetze gegen die leute die für
unseren staat den kopf hinhalten durch
rechtsprechung unterbinden lassen will
reichen ihnen 19 verletzte polizisten in
stuttgart nicht der bundesinnenminister
hat die unterstützung der gesamten
bundesregierung und natürlich auch der
bundeskanzlerin dafür dass er sich
hinter die polizisten stellt das
polizisten unseren schutz brauchen und
dass es höchst besorgniserregend ist
finden wir alle dass die anschläge oder
der angriffe auf polizisten zugenommen
haben das ist eine besorgniserregende
entwicklung die im übrigen durch gesetze
die wir gemacht haben die die polizisten
auch schützt
darauf haben wir eine antwort gegeben
zweitens ich unterstütze den
innenminister dass er den artikel wir
haben pressefreiheit das wissen sie
sicherlich zum anlass genommen hat um
ein gespräch mit dem presserat und mit
der taz zu führen um genau über die
fragen der grenzziehung zu sprechen und
ich halte das für genau den richtigen
weg und der sache hat der
bundesinnenminister meine volle
unterstützung
die kanzlerin dass sie den innenminister
von seiner klage absicht der faktor
abbringen er kommt mit seiner meinung zu
ihrem gespräch und kommt mit ihrer
meinung wieder heraus ist es weil sie
nach dem prinzip regieren hauptsache
gelenks presse steht zu uns weil sie das
seit jahren brauchen für ihre
linksverschiebung der union früher wäre
doch so eine ferne zu den eigenen
sicherheitskräften gar nicht möglich
gewesen sehen sie eigentlich überhaupt
dass sie mit alldem wie auch mit der
verhinderung einer gebotenen
strafanzeige die union bis zur
unkenntlichkeit nach links verschoben
haben und die interessen unseres landes
verraten
linksextremistische ja danke also weiß
nicht präsident ob die herrschaften sich
erst mal untereinander austauschen
wollen oder ich kann dazu nur folgendes
sagen ich weiß nicht was sie wissen ich
habe jedenfalls eine eigenschaft und die
heißt ich berichte nicht aus internen
gesprächen und der bundesinnenminister
hat die auch und insofern sage ich nur
dass ich glaube dass wir eine absolut
richtige reaktion zeigen indem wir
einerseits und hinter unsere polizisten
und sicherheitsbeamte stellen und zwar
kann nicht ausreden oder und und ich
habe die bundeskasse und zweitens indem
wir da wo wir es für notwendig halten
das gespräch suchen so geht man unter
demokraten miteinander um
die nächste frage ich tätig kollegen
heinrich spd frau dr merkel ich möchte
ihnen eine frage zur nord stream zwei
stellen dem europäisch russischen
projekt an dem sind fünf unternehmen aus
vier europäischen ländern an der
finanzierung beteiligt und die frage ist
was bedeuten die bereits in kraft
getretenen sanktionen beziehungsweise
auch die angedachten sanktionen jetzt
für die finanzierung die diese unter an
den unternehmen beteiligt sind und auch
welche unterstützung kann die
bundesregierung diesen unternehmen
angedeihen lassen
also wir haben es erst mal mit einem
wirtschaftsprojekt zu tun das natürlich
auch politische implikationen hat
deshalb hat die bundesregierung sehr
viel kraft darauf verwendet mit der
ukraine einen transitgas vertrag für die
nächsten jahre zu verhandeln um eben
nicht die ukraine abzuschneiden von den
transit dem transit von russischem gas
und damit auch von der einnahme von
transitgebühren
wir glauben allerdings dass die art der
exterritorialen sanktionen wie sie von
den vereinigten staaten von amerika
verhängt werden nicht unserem
rechtsverständnis entspricht und somit
auch nicht die zweite also die jetzt
laufenden beratungen dennoch muss man
zugestehen dass dadurch der bauverlauf
sich erschwert und wir glauben trotzdem
dass es richtig ist diesen dieses
projekt fertigzustellen und in diesem
sinne agieren wir die nächste frage
stellt die kollegen g die jensen fdp
herzlichen dank frau bundeskanzlerin 50
un experten haben am vergangenen freitag
china die missachtung fundamentaler
menschenrechte vorgeworfen darunter
waren dutzende sonderberichterstatter
der un sowie weitere un
menschenrechtsexperten in einer
gemeinsamen erklärung die sie
verabschiedet haben verurteilten sie
nicht nur die massiven einschränkungen
in hongkong massive bürgerrechts
einschränkungen die jetzt durch das von
peking verabschiedete sicherheitsgesetz
in kraft getreten sind sondern auch die
kollektive repression in regionen wie
sing sang sondern sie forderten darüber
hinaus eine sondersitzung des
un-sicherheitsrates zum vorgehen chinas
in diesen regionen und in hongkong sowie
die einsetzung eines un
sonderberichterstatters für china
deutschland übernimmt den europa- oder
den den eu ratspräsidentschaft sitz und
zusätzlich heute auch für einen monat
die vor den vorsitz im un-sicherheitsrat
und meine frage an sie ist werden sie
für eine sondersitzung zu china in den
vereinten nationen im sicherheitsrat
stimmen und damit das thema
menschenrechte auf ganz oben auf die
tagesordnung setzen und werden sie sich
für einen un sonderberichterstatter zu
china einsetzen oder das zumindest mit
unterstützen
ja also ich glaube dass wir transparenz
brauchen in fragen der menschenrechte
das ist die position der bundesregierung
die bunten die außenminister der
europäischen union haben heute zum
beispiel auch zudem sicherheitsgesetz
hongkong eine stellungnahme
verabschiedet der die ich mir natürlich
auch zu eigen mache hier wird eine große
besorgnis über dieses gesetz geäußert
und auch die menschenrechtsfragen stehen
in unseren bilateralen gesprächen mit
china inklusive auch den
menschenrechtsdialog denen wir auch
gerne in diesem jahr noch fortsetzen
wollen immer wieder auf der tagesordnung
deutschland wird sich auch im rahmen der
präsidentschaft des un-sicherheitsrates
sicherlich für diese transparenz
einsetzen und trotzdem wissen wir aus
leidvoller erfahrung dass die harmonie
im un sicherheitsrat nicht sehr groß ist
in vielen wichtigen fragen was ich
außerordentlich bedauern aber wir werden
uns für die fragen dass diese
menschenrechtsfragen auf die
tagesordnung kommen sicherlich auch
einsetzt ich habe einen
bundesaußenminister muss sich der
wahrheit halber sagen noch nicht darüber
gesprochen
wir haben viele andere dringende
zum beispiel syrien humanitäre zugänge
usw aber deutschland wird sicherlich
kein hindernis sein darüber zu sprechen
das sehen sie an der stellungnahme der
eu außenminister heute direkt zum
sicherheitsgesetz das verabschiedet
wurde und zwar sagen dort auch einige
neue regelungen die anscheinend direkt
für nicht in hongkong ansässige finden
residenz gelten sollen das ist der
artikel 38 der damit die verurteilung
und teilweise auch sogar in mainland
china im innenstadtgebiet der
volksrepublik dann stattfinden kann und
meine frage da noch einmal werden sie
sich und wird die bundesregierung
sicherstellen können dass kein deutscher
staatsbürger opfer von dieser
gerichtsbarkeit wird und der
chinesischen strafjustiz durch diesen
artikel 38 unterliegt wir werden
zumindest alles daran setzen so wie wir
das überall auf der welt tun dass unsere
staatsbürger geschützen rahn cdu csu
stehe die nächste frage frau
bundeskanzlerin
heute beginnt die ratspräsidentschaft
deutschlands eine überschrift die ich
heute gelesen habe dazu war riesige
erwartungen treffen auf gewaltige
herausforderungen ich glaube das trifft
tatsächlich ganz gut bestehen corona
bedingt vor großen wirtschaftlichen
problemen europaweit aber auch in
deutschland airbus hat heute angekündigt
17.000 arbeitsplätze abzubauen
wir werden im vergleich zum letzten jahr
über 600.000 arbeitslose mehr zählen
müssen meine frage ist angesichts dieser
situation wie kommen wir wirtschaftlich
wichtigen themen bei dem frage
innovation wettbewerbsfähigkeit
wettbewerbsrecht digitale souveränität
wir wollen wir an dieser
ratspräsidentschaft hier voranschreiten
sie sprechen die themen an die natürlich
jetzt auch mit dem sogenannten aufbau
von jahr angegangen werden sollen damit
bei einbrechenden steuereinnahmen diese
ganzen zukunftsthemen nicht auf der
strecke bleiben
die europäische kommission hat ja in
ihrem vorschlag für den aufbau von
folgende gemacht dass sie die
länderspezifischen empfehlungen für
jedes mit für jeden mitgliedsstaat nimmt
auf die defizite bezüglich der
zukunftsfähigkeit hinweist und dass das
geld war es jedem land zugeteilt wird
entsprechend seiner betroffenheit von
der pandemie dann auch genau in diese
richtungen eingibt ausgegeben wird
und da gehören dann natürlich fragen der
erhaltung unserer strategischen
fähigkeiten des aufbaus neuer
fähigkeiten der digitalen souveränität
dazu da muss jeder mitgliedstaat
natürlich seinen beitrag leisten
die besondere anstrengung ist ja auch
genau dadurch gerechtfertigt dass wir
jetzt sozusagen in einer zeit wo wir
wirtschaftlich schon alles tun müssen um
wettbewerbsfähig zu bleiben gerade auch
einbrechende steuereinnahmen haben und
deshalb uns handlungsfähigkeit durch
diesen wiederaufbau von geschaffen wir
werden auch das thema wettbewerbsrecht
und dinge die kein geld kosten leise
bürokratieabbau auf die tagesordnung
setzen und haben hier auch beim
wettbewerbsrecht einen
deutsch-französischen vorschlag
ausgearbeitet der der kommission zur
verfügung stellen wollen weil wir gerade
hier mehr auf die global champions die
sich auch in europa entwickeln können
setzen nachfrage als präsident steht ja
unter dem motto gemeinsam europa wieder
stark machen
wir merken oder beobachten dass gerade
befürchtungen bei vielen ländern da sind
dass wir durch die krise
ökonomisch noch weiter
auseinanderdriften wir wollen wir jetzt
sozusagen diese gemeinsamkeit in den
nächsten sechs monaten stärken und diese
befürchtungen entkräften indem wir eben
mit diesem wiederaufbau formen ein
zusätzliches mittel zum europäischen
haushalt haben was nicht sozusagen
nachdem bevölkerungs schlüssel
eingesetzt wird sondern nach der frage
der betroffenheit damit stellen wir
sicher dass länder die stärker betroffen
sind oder eine schlechtere
ausgangsposition haben nicht weiter
abdriften und die die lücke der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit größer wird und wir
stellen damit auch sicher dass der
binnenmarkt weiter gut funktionieren
kann was ja auch in unserem deutschen
interesse ist allerdings sage ich dazu
allein europäische maßnahmen können die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit nicht erhalten
sondern wir brauchen natürlich in jedem
mitgliedsstaat auch eigene zusätzliche
anstrengungen um die schwächen zu
überwinden so wie wir das er mit unserem
eigenen konjunkturprogramm auch als
bundesregierung oder als deutschland
machen und so müssen es alle anderen
auch zu hause machen
die linke stellt in dem geschäft vielen
danke präsident sehr geehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin die aktuelle krise zeigt
erneut das begehr der beschäftigung und
niedrige löhne keinen sozialen schutz
bieten und die gesellschaftliche
spaltung weiter befördert befristete und
leiharbeiter verlieren als erste ihren
job beschäftigte in subunternehmen
werden ausgebeutet wieder fleischskandal
aktuell zeigt und mini jobber sind
überhaupt nicht abgesichert und bislang
hat die bundesregierung nicht mal
geschafft die sachgrundlose befristung
so wie sie im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart wurde einzuschränken
hauptsächlich aufgrund des widerstands
der union und die frage sie ganz konkret
was wollen sie unternehmen um für gute
und sichere und gut entlohnte arbeit zu
sorgen damit die menschen und die
beschäftigten in diesem land keine
zukunftsängste haben müssen also im
fußball noch mal sagen wir erleben im
augenblick durch die korona pandemie den
wahrscheinlich seit langem stärksten
wirtschaftseinbruch denen wir je gesehen
haben
das heißt wir werden auswirkungen leider
auf dem arbeitsmarkt haben dass wir
heute 6,8 millionen kurzarbeiter haben
zeigt welche brücken wir bauen
sie haben aber recht zum beispiel
bestimmte beschäftigungsverhältnisse 450
euro beschäftigungsverhältnisse sind
davon nicht betroffen sind davon nicht
erfasst
die wir bauen hier andere rücken das
wissen sie auch aber wir kommen in eine
sehr ernste zeit das muss ich ganz
deutlich sagen und wir reagieren da wo
es notwendig ist zum beispiel jetzt bei
dem fleisch fragen unter fleischskandal
kann man auch sagen damit dass wir
werkverträge in genau diesen bereich
verbieten werden
wir haben bei der post zum beispiel die
die generalunternehmer haftung
eingeführt um hier auch die zahlen von
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen bei
subunternehmen möglich zu machen das
heißt also die bundesregierung reagiert
und trotzdem bleibt es eine sehr ernste
zeit in der wir leben und es wird sich
auch in den nächsten monaten noch zeigen
frage frau bundeskanzlerin die kassen
der sozialversicherung lernt sich sie an
angesprochen arbeitslosigkeit steigt
kurzarbeit steigt
und statt einem soliden
finanzierungskonzept hat jetzt die
bundesregierung mit deckelung der
sozialversicherungsbeiträge auf 40
prozent beschlossen
stimmen sie mit mir überein dass
letztendlich höhere löhne dazu beitragen
würden die kassen zu füllen und können
sie leistungskürzungen ausschließen
also ich muss man ehrlich sagen ich
erwarte ja selten unterstützung ist
sozusagen aus ihrer richtung aber dass
sie die deckelung der
sozialversicherungsbeiträge und die
tatsache dass die ausfallenden einnahmen
durch steuerzahler ersetzen also dass
der bund dann dafür eintritt dass sie
das nicht kritisieren das finde ich
bemerkenswert denn ich meine es ist doch
genau sie wissen auch genau die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge sind die
steuern des derjenigen die unterhalb der
steuerpflichtig kite verdienen also
gerade der kleinverdiener und dass wir
hier nicht die höhere arbeitslosigkeit
damit abbilden dass alle mehr
arbeitslosen versicherungsbeiträge
zahlen sondern dass wir die deckeln und
steuerzuschüsse geben dass es genau die
richtige antwort für diejenigen menschen
die wenig verdienen und dass sie das
kritisieren finde ich irgendwie
nicht wollen sich die grünen
frau bundeskanzlerin am freitag geplant
die koalition die verabschiedung eines
kohle ausstiegsgesetzes die
bundesregierung ich glaube auch sie
persönlich haben immer gesagt dass das
ergebnis der kohle kommission eins zu
eins in diesem gesetz umgesetzt werden
soll und in der tat ist es so dass
betreiber länder beschäftigte alle
werden mit großem milliarden beträgen
ich formuliere erstmal so üblich bedient
einzig und allein die klimaschutz seite
da wird ganz erheblich von dem ergebnis
der kohle kommission abgewiesen und das
kommissions- ergebnis nicht umgesetzt
das geht so weit dass
kommissionsmitglieder davon sprechen
dass das ergebnis aufgekündigt wird dass
sie sagen dieser gesetzentwurf hätte er
in der kommission zur abstimmung
gestanden hätte nie die notwendige
mehrheit bekommen und das ist objektiv
so da kann man auch nicht dran vorbei
gucken
meine frage an sie wäre wann und warum
wurde entschieden einseitig vom
kommissions- ergebnis abzuweichen und
das gesetz im sinne des klimaschutzes
deutlich zu verbessern
na ja ich würde sagen erstens ist es
eine ein großer schritt wenn wir am
freitag verlässlichkeit in den ausstieg
aus der kohleverstromung bringen
die ergebnisse der kommission sind
dahingehend in den kernpunkten auch
aufgenommen dass wir das ausstiegsdatum
und die möglichkeit dass auch
vorzuziehen wenn revisionen und
überprüfungen das
hergeben weiter erhalten zweitens was
den klimaschutz und die maßnahmen gerade
bepreisung von co2 anbelangt bin ich
sehr froh dass wir in weiten konsens
inklusive bundesrat wo ja die grünen
auch immer mit dabei sind gefunden haben
mit unserem klima paket am ende des
jahres das ergänzt dass kohle paket und
zweitens würde man es und drittens würde
ich mal sagen ich bin sehr dankbar dass
es die kohle kommission gab
ohne sie wären wir heute nicht da wo wir
sind aber das wie knauserig war bei der
entschädigung und begleitung des
strukturwandels mit 40 milliarden kann
man auch nicht sagen und insofern haben
wir da auch ganz schön zu tun um diesen
strukturwandel sozialverträglich zu
gestalten
nach machen aber herzlichen dank für
bundeskanzler für ihre leute um sie
haben nur leider nicht auf meine frage
geantwortet die war wann und wo
entschieden worden ist das vom
kommissions- ergebnisse bei fragen
vielleicht sagen dann würde es konkret
nach wie vor genau dann würde ich
konkret nachfragen warum ist entschieden
worden dass beispielsweise der tagebau
garzweiler zu energiepolitischen
notwendigkeit erklärt werden soll
wann ist entschieden worden dass die
abschalten folge der ostdeutschen
braunkohlekraftwerke nach hinten
verschoben wird wann ist entschieden
worden alles gegen das votum der kohle
kommission dass zur feier des kohle
ausstiegs das kraftwerk datteln in
betrieb gehen soll
ich könnte ihnen reihe von weiteren
punkten aufzählen all das müssen sie mir
erläutern wo genau man das entschieden
worden ist dass man hier ganz bewusst
vom votum der kohle kommission abweichen
will
ja wir haben verschiedene gespräche
geführt das haben sich auch zum teil in
der detailbetrachtung wie gehört ein
tagebau zum beispiel mit dem produzenten
zusammen wir sind die
eigentumsverhältnisse haben sich schon
noch mal verschiebungen ergeben im
grundsatz folgen wer dem ausstiegs fahrt
und den vorgaben was die
produktionsmenge anbelangt einigermaßen
ich weiß dass wir hänger haben in der
mitte der 20er jahre
aber einigermaßen dem pfad und ich
glaube wir haben
was großes geschafft dass die kohle
kommission für uns sozusagen dass er die
eins zu eins umsetzen das haben wir
nicht gesagt wir haben gesagt wir folgen
dem duktus dass es da vielleicht auch
enttäuschungen bei den mitgliedern gibt
dass sie sich noch mehr erwartet hätten
das glaube ich ich finde insgesamt ist
das ein ganz ganz wichtiger schritt den
wir jetzt gehen die nächste frage steht
ihr kollege wenn ihr springen steht ja
vielen dank herr präsident frau
bundeskanzlerin die ikone maßnahmen der
bundes und landesregierung der
länderregierungen haben zu verheerenden
auswirkungen auf dem arbeitsmarkt
geführt
stand heute morgen haben wir 637.000
krone bringt der arbeitslose wir haben
im zeitraum märz bis mai einen anstieg
der arbeitslosigkeit bei deutschen um 19
prozent erlebt bei ausländern um 24
prozent für 12 millionen menschen ist
kurzarbeit angezeigt wurden dass es
jeder dritte sozialversicherung
versicherungspflichtiger beschäftigung
beschäftigte wir haben viele
kurzarbeiter die nicht mehr in die
beschäftigung zurückkehren werden
zugleich sehen wir das mit dem 2009/10
beschlossenen fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetz ausländische
arbeitskräfte angeworben werden und dass
dort keine vorrangprüfung mehr
vorgesehen ist für uns als fdp fraktion
stehen die heimischen beschäftigten und
die die jetzt ihren job verloren haben
an erster stelle und meine frage an sie
ist stehen diese beschäftigten auch für
sie und die bundesregierung an erster
stelle und sind sie bereit auch hier ein
signal auszusenden und dass fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetz auszusetzen
zumindest aber die vorrangprüfung wieder
einzuführen
danke sehr also dazu bin ich nicht
bereit das fachkräfte ein neues gesetz
auszusetzen denn sie wissen auch dass
uns fachkräfte in ganz bestimmten
bereichen fehlen die für die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit und für andere
arbeitsplätze in der bundesrepublik
deutschland für den erhalt solcher
arbeitsplätze unabdingbar sind
aber natürlich haben wir eine schwierige
entwicklung auf dem arbeitsmarkt die ist
aber nicht weil wir sozusagen etwas
politisch falsch entschieden haben
sondern sie ist deshalb weil eine
pandemie über die welt gekommen ist und
ich bin sehr froh dass wir leben
retten konnten durch kluge maßnahmen was
woanders ganz anders aussieht und dass
wir gleichzeitig alles dafür tun unsere
wirtschaft zu stark wie möglich aus
dieser krise herauskommen zu lassen und
vielen menschen
beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten zu
ermöglichen
[Applaus]
ja ich möchte doch das thema zuwanderung
noch mal zu sprechen kommen
beziehungsweise auch auf die folgen
ihrer gescheiterten zuwanderungspolitik
wir haben heute zwei millionen ausländer
im hartz-iv-bezug wir haben 100.000
ausländer die ununterbrochen seit 15
jahren hartz 4 beziehen 100.000
ausländer auf der anderen seite haben
wir beschäftigte die stehen um 4 uhr auf
arbeiten nach 35 jahren berufserfahrung
zum mindestlohn zahlen dann noch steuern
um diesen irrsinn zu finanzieren was
sagen sie diesen menschen heute wie wird
es weitergehen
ich finde man sollte nicht schon in
einer frage eine spaltung der
gesellschaft anliegen wieso überhaupt
nicht existiert ich glaube dass es unter
dem strich richtig dass es richtig war
dass wir humanitär gehandelt haben und
auch heute an verschiedenen stellen
humanitär handeln
ich glaube dass es zweitens wichtig ist
dass wir zuwanderung und auch migration
und flucht steuern und ordnen da sind
wir vorangekommen aber längst nicht am
ende des weges das wird auch eine in der
rats präsidentschaft eine große rolle
spielen und drittens sind natürlich und
sie haben es ja selbst gesagt diejenigen
die eine zuwanderungsgeschichte haben
sogar im zweifelsfalle stärker sozial
betroffen weil sie vielleicht manchmal
auch noch nicht das bildungsniveau
erreicht haben aber ich muss ihnen sagen
ich habe neulich in fürth hin gesehen
ein video als unsere familienministerin
jungen schülern die 2016 15 zu uns
gekommen sind und die alle mit 1 abitur
gemacht haben die zeugnisse übergeben
haben und da kann ich nur sagen es gibt
auch diese geschichten und ich können
sie auch manchmal in ihrer ausführungen
zu worte kommen müssen
dr johannes rau spd
die nächste frage frau bundeskanzlerin
gestern lief der kündigungsschutz für
die mieterinnen und mieter aus bis zum 3
6 6 1 war befristet die kündigung
zumindest jetzt sofort ausgeschlossen
der deutsche mieterbund hat wie ich
finde sehr eindrücklich dargelegt dass
viele mieterinnen und mieter in
wirtschaftlicher not sind sie haben
selber gesagt dass wir mit steigenden
arbeitslosenzahlen rechnen müssen und
auch aus dem gaststättengewerbe
da hören wir die klare forderung dieses
moratorium zu verlängern
deswegen habe ich kein verständnis das
sie und die unions mitglieder des
bundeskabinetts sich der verlängerung
also dass auch die mieten juli august
und september
ausgenommen sind von einer kündigung
dass sie diesen vorschlag der spd nicht
zugestimmt habe ich finde wir können die
mieterinnen und mieter in dieser
schwierigen situation nicht im regen
stehen lassen
also erstens möchte ich nur soviel sagen
dass wir dazu eine sehr vielschichtige
wahnsinn noch nicht fertig erstens
deutlich sagen dass wir dazu in der
bundesregierung eine vielschichtige
diskussion hatten die möchte ich jetzt
mal nicht im detail ausführen aber egal
die entscheidung haben wir uns nicht
leicht gemacht wir haben in der abwägung
dass diese regelung ein sehr tief
greifender eingriff in die
vertragsfreiheit ist und dass es auch
vermieter gibt die sehr große
wirtschaftliche probleme haben haben wir
uns entschieden angesichts der anderen
maßnahmen die wir als
unterstützungsmaßnahmen haben zum
beispiel jetzt für mittelständler nicht
nur kredite sondern durch das programm
des wirtschaftsministers peter altmaier
auch zuschüsse dass wir es verantworten
können und das sage ich aus voller
überzeugung dass wir diese maßnahmen
nicht verlängert haben sondern jetzt zum
beispiel für mittelständische
unternehmen wenn sie mit ihren mietern
nicht klarkommt zuschüsse haben wenn sie
einbrüche hatten ich glaube das ist der
mildere eingriff in die vertragsfreiheit
denn ich kenne auch vermieter die
ziemlich unruhig waren wenn sie jetzt
über sechs monate keine mieteinnahmen
haben und selber dann wieder in
schwierigkeiten kommen also in der
gesamtsumme glaube ich dass wir vorsorge
getroffen haben durch neue instrumente
so dass die verlängerung nicht notwendig
war aber darüber gab es einen dissenz
das ist richtig frau bundeskanzlerin ich
finde da haben sie die dramatik der
situation nicht ganz begriffen
wir haben insbesondere alleinerziehende
oder kleine firmen die jetzt große
sorgen haben über die runden zu kommen
viele von denen hatten ja noch rücklagen
mit denen sie über die monate märz april
auch noch den main gekommen sind die
sind jetzt aber aufgezehrt deswegen wäre
meine nachfrage ob das jetzt ein
komplette absage an ein solches
kündigungs moratorium ist oder ob die
bundesregierung zumindest heute hier die
zusage geben kann dass sie die situation
im auge behalten und wenn sich die lage
von dir leider ausgehen müssen
verschärft ein solches kündigungs
moratorium doch wieder einführen also
erstmals das gesetz ja bis 30.9 sowieso
befristet gewesen ist drei monate
erstmal angelegt dann hätte es eine
kappe minister peer ordnung mit
zustimmung des bundeskabinetts gegeben
um das noch einmal bis ende september zu
erweitern davon haben wir jetzt nicht
gebrauch gemacht aber ende september
läuft das gesetz aus wir betrachten
alles und haben alles im blick das
wissen sie wir haben jetzt ganz
ungewöhnliche entscheidungen und sehr
schnell getroffen aber ich kann heute
keine zusagen machen weil ich vor allen
dingen hoffe dass wir nicht immer wieder
über diese schwierige situation sprechen
sondern wer die wirtschaft wieder ans
laufen kriegen
daran sollten wir arbeiten und ansonsten
kümmern wir uns wirklich um die
verschiedenen konstellationen sehr
intensiv
gerald ulrich fdp steht die nächste
frage vielen dank frau bundeskanzlerin
ich habe eine frage bezüglich der gwb
novelle in den vergangenen monaten haben
die digitalen plattformen und der online
handel generell einen großen schub
erhalten durch die korona krise hingegen
sind kleinere handelsunternehmen und
auch mittelständler und wie wir
die letzten tagen erfahren haben auch
große unternehmen schon stark davon
betroffen von dieser krise gleichzeitig
wurde in den vergangenen monaten immer
wieder die änderung des gesetzes gegen
wettbewerbsbeschränkung beschränkungen
verschoben
es gab einen referentenentwurf vom
januar und im kabinett war es glaube ich
anfang märz wurde aber auch dort immer
wieder verschoben weil es probleme gab
zwischen der justizministerin und dem
wirtschaftsminister die die wissenschaft
wand inzwischen schon dass wir als
größte volkswirtschaft in europa endlich
ein gesetz verabschieden müssen da sonst
zu starken schäden kommen kann deshalb
meine frage werden sie sich verstärkt
dafür einsetzen dass der widerspruch
oder die blockadehaltung des
justizministeriums aufgehoben wird und
dort die zusammenarbeit mit dem
wirtschaftsministerium endlich
stattfindet damit wir in kürze hier auch
über einen gesetzentwurf ihrer
bundesregierung reden können also ich
hab jetzt am wochenende mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister über die gwb
novelle gesprochen weil ich finde sie
muss kommen und sie ist auch notwendig
die justizministerin ist auch gar nicht
bezüglich dieser gwb novelle so
ablehnend also damit hier kein falscher
eindruck entsteht manchmal gibt es so
was was man pakete nennt in der politik
und es ist nicht das einzige gesetz war
es noch nicht auf die tagesordnung
gekommen ist wir werden über die
sommerpause intensiv daran arbeiten
damit sie im herbst über eine gb modelle
beraten könnte ich halte sie auch für
notwendig
[Musik]
die gwb novelle ist natürlich wie gesagt
sehr wichtig schon dass sie das auch so
sehen aber es ist ja nur ein kleiner
schritt bezüglich eines europäischen
digital rechten wettbewerbsrecht ist wir
haben nun ab heute den sie haben nun den
ratspräsidenten die ratspräsidentschaft
in europa werden sie sich im nächsten
halben jahr auch dafür einsetzen dass es
dort in europa auch ein digital gesetz
geben wird und denken sie dass wir dazu
eine eigene behörde brauchen naja jetzt
von der fdp gehen dann haben behörde
gefragt zu werden ist auch ein bisschen
erstaunlich aber da hatte ich hätte
nicht mit gerechnet wir werden auf jeden
fall neue rechtliche regelungen brauchen
in europa nicht nur übrigens im
digitalbereich was das wettbewerbsrecht
anbelangt sondern wie ich zum kollegen
haben schon gesagt hatte insgesamt ich
glaube dass wir bezüglich der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit gegenüber dem rest
der welt erheblichen nachholbedarf auch
auf europäischer ebene haben und wir
werden uns genau dafür einsetzen im
digitalen bereich aber auch in anderen
bereichen
gunther krichbaum cdu csu stellt die
nächsten morgen
vielen dank herr präsident frau
bundeskanzlerin mit der übernahme der
ratspräsidentschaft übernehmen wir
natürlich auch ein hohes maß an
erwartungen aber ein schwerpunkt unserer
ratspräsidentschaft soll ja auch die
außen- und sicherheitspolitik sein
möchte aber den blick in den kontext
zwar aber auf etwas anderes denken
nämlich hier den einsatz nato-einsatz
sieg guardian
hier gab es ein zehnter juni einen
zwischenfall als dass ich eben türkische
schiffe den französischen nährten die
eigentlich nichts anderes machen wollten
als ein großes schiff der ein
frachtschiff der unter panamaischer
flagge zu kontrollieren
daraufhin wurden die französischen
schiffe unter feuer genommen
der vorfall wird in frankreich als sehr
ernst bewertet hat auch schon zu einer
untersuchung jetzt geführt eine
eingeleitete untersuchung auf nato ebene
meine frage ist die wie bewertet die
bundesregierung diese vorkommnisse
gegenüber ländern und partnern innerhalb
desselben bündnissen nämlich der nato ja
wir nehmen das auch sehr ernst sicher
für den französischen präsidenten jetzt
auch über diesen vorfall gesprochen es
wird in der nato untersucht was dort
stattgefunden hat der
untersuchungsbericht ist noch nicht
fertig aber wir sollten alles
daransetzen dass unter nato
mitgliedsstaaten solche vorfälle nicht
sich wiederholen
das ist sehr ernst eine nachfrage eine
nachfrage sei mir gestattet
wir begrüßen dass auch denke ich auch in
der sat mehrheit das im europaausschuss
das eben eine sehr große verbindung auch
mit frankreich herrscht stimmen zentrale
politikbereiche ab auch über die trio
präsidentschaft hinweg was sehr gut ist
weil ja frankreich in der ersten
jahreshälfte 2022 dann die
ratspräsidentschaft übernimmt noch mal
den blick auf die türkei gelenkt nach
meiner wahrnehmung gibt es bis zum
heutigen tage keine kohärente eu
strategie im hinblick auf die türkei
gibt es hier denn
schon die erste verständigung zwischen
der bundesregierung und frankreich in
dieser hinsicht da erste schritte in
diese richtung zu unternehmen
beziehungsweise sie hat mir auch
kürzlich ein treffen vor wenigen tagen
mit herrn makro mit präsident makro
vielleicht können sie auch hier noch
berichten was hier gegenstand auch
dieses treffens und dieser unterredungen
war ja wir brauchen eine kohärente
türkei strategie und die muss zwei
elemente umfassen auf der einen seite
oder mindestens zwei auf der einen seite
die tatsache dass wir strategisch
miteinander verbunden sind dass wir zum
beispiel in der nato gemeinsam sind aber
auch die bewältigung der
flüchtlingsfrage gelingt nur stichwort
eu türkei abkommen wenn man hier auch
miteinander absprachen trifft weil soll
man sonst auf dem rücken der menschen
arbeitet wir haben das thema libyen wir
haben das thema syrien und mit sehr sehr
vielen facetten und auf der anderen
seite haben wir natürlich kritik zu üben
an vielen dingen auch was
menschenrechtsfragen in der türkei
anbelangt und dass beides zusammen zu
bekommen ist sehr wichtig wir haben
jetzt die erschwernis dass die türkei
vor zypern und griechenland buchungen
durchführt vorüber als eine große
kontroverse gibt und hier arbeiten wir
daran dass wir wieder zu gesprächen
kommen zwischen den betroffenen wie es
zum beispiel auch bis 2016 der fall war
also deutschland versucht hier den
verschiedenen facetten des verhältnisses
zur türkei gerecht zu werden das ist
nicht immer einfach und das gelingt nur
mit frankreich zusammen da haben sie
vollkommen recht
nicole gohlke die linke steht die
nächste folge vielen dank herr präsident
frau bundeskanzlerin als
wissenschaftspolitische sprecherin
meiner fraktion erreichen mich in diesen
tagen sehr viele hilferufe von
studierenden hunderttausende studierende
haben ihre nebenjobs verloren und können
von den eltern jetzt auch nicht mehr so
wie früher unterstützt werden
bei vielen steht sogar die frage im raum
ob ein studienabbruch droht stadt jetzt
einfach das bafög zu öffnen das wäre ja
eine ziemlich nahe liegende lösung
gewesen hat ihre bildungsministerin
lediglich kredite zur verfügung gestellt
und bietet damit eigentlich nur die
option einer verschuldung für die jungen
menschen an
es gibt nur für ganz wenige studierende
die möglichkeit einer überbrückungshilfe
von maximal 500 euro im konjunktur und
zukunftspaket der regierung fehlen die
studierenden auch völlig und ich finde
es steht in keinem verhältnis wenn die
regierungen für die jungen menschen so
wenig gelder zur verfügung stellt und
auf der anderen seite aber die förderung
der rüstungsindustrie im konjunkturpaket
mit zehn milliarden euro
bereist sie sagen ja haben sie gerade
auch ausgeführt eingangs ihnen liegen
die chancen der jungen menschen am
herzen dann frage ich sie welche
zusätzlichen maßnahmen planen sie zur
unterstützung von studierenden hier
fallen also darf ja nicht der eindruck
entstehen dass es jetzt kein bafög mehr
gibt sondern es war ja nur die frage
öffnen wir bafög sozusagen für alle die
betroffen sein könnten
das wollten wir nicht aus gründen auch
der ordnungspolitik sage ich jetzt mal
deshalb haben wir dieses kreditprogramm
gemacht und ich glaube dass das ein
erster wichtiger schritt ist und so wie
eben gesagt wurde müssen wir natürlich
die situation der studierenden uns auch
weiter anschauen
aber ich glaube wir den jetzigen
zeitpunkt ist der erste schritt sehr
wichtig nachfragen ja gerne
also wenn es bei den jetzigen maßnahme
der bundesregierung bleibt dann wird
diese krise auch im bildungsbereich zu
einer ganz massiven weiteren sozialen
spaltung führen und von dem möglichen
studienabbruch denen ich jetzt gerade
skizziert habe sind ja vor allem
diejenigen betroffen die eben aus
nichtakademischen haushalten kommen
diejenigen die keine wohlhabenden eltern
haben wie wollen sie diese spaltung in
arm und reich die wir im gesamten
bildungsbereich haben und die sich jetzt
auch im hochschulbereich m fortführt wie
wollen sie die verhindern
also ich will man sagen seit nämlich
bundeskanzlerin ist die zahl der
studierenden an deutschen hochschulen
rasant gestiegen und das kann also nicht
so eine schlechte politik gewesen sein
dann stimmen sie mir sicherlich zu
zweitens sind ja gerade die die aus
elternhäusern kommen wo die eltern nicht
so viel verdienen diejenigen die bafög
bekommen und insofern sehe ich also ihr
problem jetzt nicht was sie gerade
eröffnung
sie haben zwei kinder sollen sich die
grünen bestellt den fc bayern ja dass
hier alle kann auch nicht gelingen frau
bundeskanzlerin die situation auf dem
mittelmeer beunruhigt mich beunruhigt
meine fraktion enormen vielerlei
hinsicht die lage in griechenland
die zurückdrängung von geflüchteten die
nach wie vor hohe zahl von ertrinkenden
menschen im mittelmeer das fehlen einer
europäischen lösung im rahmen des
zwanzigsten flüchtlingsschutz symposiums
hat der parlamentarische staatssekretär
stephan mayer der ist auch anwesend
heute gesagt dass er es für falsch hält
das die evangelische kirche mit einem
eigenen schiff in das seegebiet
aufbricht um menschen zu retten
er sagte auch dass es keine europäisch
koordinierte seenotrettung braucht
begründet hatte das mit der einer
formiert mission irini von der wir aber
ja wissen dass wir in einem ganz anderen
einsatzgebiet operiert und die ja dieses
diese mission gibt ja auch die
mitgliedstaaten die möglichkeit sich im
falle von zu vielen rettung aus dem
seegebiet zurückzuziehen ist also
mitnichten eine lösung deshalb möchte
ich auch wegen der vielen
unterschiedlichen äußerungen die wir
immer wieder von dem von ihnen gerne
wissen ob sie eine europäisch
koordinierte seenotrettung für richtig
halten ob sie sich auch im rahmen der
ratspräsidentschaft dafür einsetzen
werden ich halte ich halte erst einmal
für richtig und wichtig dass wir es
schaffen dass wir die migration sehr
viel besser steuern und alle diese
seenotrettung egal ob sie über die
europäische union durchgeführt werden
oder ob sie mit privaten seenotrettung
durchgeführt werden sind immer nur die
zweitbeste lösung denn wir müssen
eigentlich verhindern dass menschen sich
überhaupt so in gefahr bringen deshalb
werden wir auch weiter daran arbeiten
dass wir gerade auch in libyen
bedingungen schaffen mit denen auch der
un acr arbeiten kann ich weiß dass wir
da weit entfernt sind wir teilen
übrigens die besorgnisse alle sowohl was
zwischen der türkei und griechenland
stattfindet auf der ägäis als auch was
auf dem mittelmeer zwischen italien und
libyens stattfindet ist alles andere als
zufriedenstellend das hat das
bundesinnenministerium auch das thema
europäische asylpolitik als ein
wichtiges thema für die
ratspräsidentschaft benannt wir wissen
aber alle dass wir das nicht so schnell
lösen könnte es dann müssen wir
natürlich humanitär handeln das ist
richtig aber wir dürfen auch nicht den
eindruck erwecken dass menschen
sozusagen in eine gefährliche situation
sich bringen sollen denn wir sehen
tragischerweise dass auch viele menschen
ihr leben auf diesem weg verlieren gerne
vielen dank dass das eine die andere
situation wo wir auch direkt in der
verantwortung stehen sind die jetzt
wiederholt zahlreiche dokumentierten und
illegalen push back zurückweisungen von
geflüchteten an europäischen land und
seegrenzen ja und sie werden sicher mit
mir übereinstimmen ja es sind unsere
grenzen unserer gemeinsamen grenzen
unsere werte und es ist inakzeptabel
wenn internationales und europäisches
recht an dieser stelle gebrochen wird
deshalb auch hier nochmal die frage sie
sind dokumentiert mittlerweile wirklich
ohne dass man noch fragen haben könnte
dazu was nicht gelingt ist die
aufklärung und das zur rechenschaft
ziehen der verantwortlichen weil immer
wieder auf andere akteure verwiesen wird
findet das im frontex verbund stadt war
es die griechische küstenwache werden
sie sich im rahmen der kommenden monaten
dafür einsetzen dass solche vorfälle
lückenlos aufgeklärt werden und vor
allem die verantwortlichen dann auch zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden bei dieser
vorgang beschädigt europa und seine
werte massiv wir wollen wir wollen eure
völkerrecht und internationales recht
natürlich einhalten das ist absolut
richtig
ich werde mich vor allen dingen dazu an
dafür einsetzen dass es gar nicht erst
zu solchen situationen kommt sondern
dass wir mit der türkei besprechen dass
solche
situationen nicht entstehen denn wir
stehen natürlich in einem
spannungsverhältnis zwischen dem schutz
der außengrenzen und was wir dort zum
beispiel in der landgrenze zwischen der
türkei und griechenland erlebt haben das
war im grunde politik auf dem rücken
auch von flüchtlingen und das darf sich
nicht wiederholen und dafür werde ich
mich vor allen dingen einsetzen wo es
rechtsverletzungen kommen sollte werden
wir uns auch dafür einsetzen dass
aufzuklären darum geht das nicht aber
das ist kein mechanismus wenn man
sozusagen immer sich in gefahr bringen
muss um sozusagen eine eu außengrenze zu
überwinden sondern wir brauchen
geregelte abkommen mit den
nachbarstaaten auf dem und das dazu
gehört eben auch die türkei und dafür
werde ich mich weiter einsetzen und da
bin ich bedauerlicherweise oft sehr
kritisiert worden
ich sehe aber keine andere möglichkeit
die humanitärer wäre als das bier auch
mit finanzieller unterstützung dafür
sorgen dass die flüchtlinge dort wo sie
leben auch gut leben können und
ansonsten geordnet und geregelt zwischen
staaten verabreden was wir miteinander
tun
kollege leif erik holm afd
vielen dank herr präsident frau
bundeskanzlerin am 15 mai ist in
mecklenburg vorpommern eine frau zur
landesverfassungsgericht drinnen gewählt
worden
die einer als linksextremistisch
eingestufte vereinigung angehörte
antikapitalistischen linken sie hat sie
sogar mit gegründet und sie hat sich
bisher nicht davon distanziert entgegen
teil bis heute verharmlost sie den
mauerbau sie verhöhnt die mauertoten ist
bei einer gedenk minute im landtag sogar
demonstrativ sitzengeblieben
sie hat wohl auch in ddr-zeiten als
bürgermeisterin allen
republikflüchtlingen das haus abgepresst
und eine solche frau als
verfassungsrichterin zu wählen ist aus
meiner sicht unerträglich und
unerträglich dass waren auch die worte
des verfassungsschutz chefs halten
banken in der sache der
csu-generalsekretär blume hat gesagt wer
verfassungs weit ist kann kein hüter der
verfassung sein
das ist absolut richtig wasser leider
vergessen hat dass seine schwester
partei ihre partei in gestalt der
cdu-landtagsfraktion
mecklenburg-vorpommern dieser wahl
zugestimmt hat teilen sie also die
auffassungen von herrn haldenwang
und von herrn blume und was folgt aus
dieser position
also ich teile die position dieser
verfassungsrichterin absolut nicht und
das brauche ich glaube ich nicht weiter
zu begründen
es hat dann im landtag ein sehr
komplexes verfahren gegeben mit vielen
implikationen und ich weiß wovon ich
spreche und dass ihnen das nicht gefällt
und das ist lieber gehabt hätten die cdu
hätte mit ihnen zusammen gestimmt kann
nicht verstehen
hat sie aber nicht gemacht und so ist
ein sicherlich unbefriedigendes ergebnis
dabei herausgekommen ich respektiere
aber die entscheidung abwägung der
kolleginnen und kollegen im landtag
mecklenburg vorpommern und das ist
manchmal das ist manchmal politik dass
man auch zur resultaten kommt die nicht
umfassend gut sind ja diese antwort
überrascht mich jetzt ein bisschen ich
meine danke überrascht mich schon weil
wir wissen dass sie da auch sehr laut
und deutlich reagieren können zum
beispiel auf einem staatsbesuch in
südafrika als sie darauf hinwiesen dass
ein fdp mann nicht ministerpräsident
werden könnte in thüringen und dass das
rückgängig gemacht werden müsse da hätte
ich mir von ihr jetzt von ihnen jetzt
auch eine klare antwort mal gewünscht in
der sache denn soweit ich weiß gibt es
ja in ihrer partei keine unvereinbarkeit
beschluss also stellt sich schon die
frage wie es möglich ist dass eine
solche verfassungsrichterin mit der cdu
gewählt werden kann und da würden sich
die bürger tatsächlich glaube ich mal
eine starke position eine positionierung
von ihnen wünschen
ja da dies nun ich habe das gesagt was
ich dazu gesagt habe dass das nun nicht
umfassend befriedigend es kann nicht gut
verstehen spd steht die nächste frage
vielen dank herr präsident frau
bundeskanzlerin die korona pandemie
zeigt dass frauen in der
krisenbewältigung an vorderster front in
der ersten reihe stehen wenn wir aber in
die wirtschaft in die führungsetagen der
wirtschaft stehen sehen wir dass frauen
in der vordersten reihe massiv
unterrepräsentiert sind deswegen
ist meine frage wie stehen sie als
bundeskanzlerin zu den vorschlag
vorschlägen unserer ministerin franziska
gefallen und christine lambrecht die
quote für frauen auf mehr unternehmen
auszuweiten und eine mindestvorgabe für
vorstände einzuführen
ja ich bin mit der ministerin in einem
engen gespräch und deshalb möchte ich da
jetzt aus den gesprächen nichts hier
schon verraten weil wir noch nicht am
ende der gespräche sind ich halte es für
absolut unzureichend dass es immer noch
börsennotierte unternehmen gibt in denen
nicht eine einzige frau im vorstand ist
das ist ein zustand den kann man nicht
vernünftig finden wir haben gesehen dass
bei dem bei unserer quotenregelung in
den aufsichtsräten sich plötzlich
ausreichend und genügend frauen gefunden
haben und jetzt geben sie mir noch ein
bisschen zeit mit der ministerin weiter
zu beraten
das ich kenne meine grenzen der amtszeit
da braucht sich keiner sorgen habe ich
öffentlich verkündet weil es schön
natürlich geben wir ihnen die zeit
trotzdem zeigt uns einfach die momentane
situation dass wir das auch vielleicht
beschleunigen müssen um die situation zu
ändern deswegen erlauben sie mir ganz
konkret die nachfrage setzen sie sich
mit uns gemeinsam dafür ein dass wir die
mindestvorgabe für vorstände in den von
ihnen angesprochenen unternehmen
gesetzlich festlegen
schauen sie ich setze mich dafür ein
dass wir für gute lösungen gute
mehrheiten bekommen krieg gegen den aus
dem rhythmus fdp spielt die nächste
frage herr präsident frau
bundeskanzlerin unter welchen
voraussetzungen ist nach ihrer ansicht
eine epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite der bundesregierung ja
sonderrechte gewährt unter welchen
voraussetzungen ist sie nicht mehr
vorhanden und zeigen nicht die
derzeitigen vorfälle dass die bewertung
der situation gerade regional auf
landesebene erfolgen muss
also mit sicherheit ist sie nicht
erforderlich wenn man impfstoff haben
und medikamente aber die epidemische
lage ist ja auch vorher zeitlich schon
begrenzt das war ja auch ein wunsch des
deutschen bundestages den ich absolut
verstehen
inwieweit wir davon sprechen können dass
wir wirklich regionale begrenzungen
haben oder inwieweit ist eine große
gefahr gibt das jetzt auch gerade wenn
viele menschen hin und her fahren im
urlaub und ähnliches sich das wieder
weiter ausbreiten kann darüber haben wir
noch keine abschließenden erkenntnisse
deshalb glaube ich dass jetzt nicht die
stunde ist nach der beendigung der
epidemischen lage zu fragen sondern
wirklich alle kraft darauf zu setzen die
lokalen ereignisse auch lokal zu halten
so gerne wir haben ein
wissenschaftliches gutachten erstellen
lassen und danach ist eine epidemische
lage dann nicht mehr gegeben oder dann
gegeben wenn eine überforderung des
öffentlichen gesundheitswesens vorliegt
und die länder nicht eigenständig in der
lage sind das zu regeln dass da komme
ich jetzt zu der frage sehen sie
wirklich diese zentrale steuerung als
weiterhin gegeben an und heißt es nicht
dass sie dann indirekt auch sagen herr
laschet in nordrhein-westfalen und herr
söder in bayern sind dazu nicht mehr in
der lage und deswegen muss es bedarf es
eben einer zentralen steuerung auf
bundesebene
das ist ja nicht schwarz und ich weiß
die der landkreis gütersloh hat jetzt
zum beispiel darum gebeten dass die
bundeswehr dort hinkommt und unterstützt
und das ist auch in großem umfang
geschehen und genau das werden wir auch
weiter tun wenn sie das als notwendig
angesehen wird wir haben in unserem
konjunkturprogramm erheblichen mittel
bereitgestellt um den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst auch zu stärken weil
die kontakt nachverfolgung gewährleistet
sein muss und gerade auch bei den vielen
hygiene konzepten die jetzt gemacht sind
ist der öffentliche gesundheitsdienst
unglaublich unter stress und ich bin den
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern da
sehr dankbar was sie leisten das heißt
wir sind sozusagen ein stück
vorangekommen gemessen an der
anfangszeit aber ich persönlich sage
ihnen dass ich nicht ruhig bin in bezug
auf die ausbreitung des virus sie
vielleicht auch nicht und dass sich
deshalb glaube dass wir gut daran tun
jetzt nicht einfach zu sagen wir sind
aus aus dem aus der gefahr und ich
glaube auch dass wir sehr sorgsam mit
den zusätzlichen kompetenzen des bundes
durch die epidemische lage um
mit dem parlament das eng diskutieren
und das werden wir auch weiter in der
verbleibenden zeit zu machen
die zusätzliche kohle vielen dank herr
präsident ich möchte mal auf dieses
gutachten zurückkommen dieser begriff
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite ist die juristisch der erste
begriff der extrem weitgehende eingriffe
in menschenrechte und bürgerrechte
begründet und dann kann das doch nur
auch nach diesem gutachten aber von
meiner persönlichen überzeugung doch nur
gerechtfertigt sein wenn dringend der
handlungsbedarf besteht und ich kann
einfach nicht verstehen wie vielleicht
können sie mir helfen wenn in gütersloh
und an anderen orten örtlich große
infektionszahlen bestehen wieso muss
dann in drei viertel bundesgebietes wohl
kaum infektionen sind warum müssen da
dieselben begrenzung gelten wie sie bei
den gütersloher angemessen sind das kann
ich nicht verstehen da brüste stolz
nicht verstehen juristisch kann ich
ihnen da auch wenig helfen weil ich
keine juristin bin also ich kann das
jetzt nur zur kenntnis nehmen dass sie
als jurist schwierigkeiten haben
politisch sage ich ihnen dass die lage
die jetzt in gütersloh oder in
berlin-neukölln aufgetreten ist oder in
bayern am starnberger see und mit dem
caterer dass die an jeder stelle in der
republik jederzeit entstehen kann und
ich weiß nicht ob wir dann jeweils
einmal ein gesetz zu machen ein gesetz
zu machen und deshalb glaube ich dass
wir doch auch durch die permanente
überprüfung durch die gerichte durch die
einschränkung der grundrechte die wir
vornehmen
und ja auch die tatsache dass da dann so
geurteilt wird dass manches akzeptiert
wird man anderes aber auch wieder in
frage gestellt wird dass wir eine offene
demokratische atmosphäre haben trotz der
epidemischen lage und eben nicht
unverhältnismäßig von den möglichkeiten
gebrauch machen sondern in der
epidemischen lage heute völlig anders
agieren als wir das vor am anfang der
eingeführten massnahmen tun das ist
verhältnismäßig das ist richtig aber die
situation ist so unsicher dass sich die
epidemische lage weiter für gegeben
hatte
die nächste frage und kollege dr anja
weisgerber cdu/csu serie frau
bundeskanzlerin die themen
nachhaltigkeit und klimaschutz spielen
jahr in der eu ratspräsidentschaft eine
zentrale rolle
dass es auch gut so klimaneutralität bis
2050 ist das ziel für europa deutschland
geht mit dem klimapaket ja mit gutem
beispiel voran wie motivieren wir die
anderen staaten europas hier dem auch
mitzuziehen und nachzuziehen und auch
die klimaneutralität zu ihrem ziel zu
erklären
ja wir haben wir von allen
mitgliedstaaten außer polen schon die
zusage dass man sich zur
klimaneutralität 2050 bekennt polen hat
hier noch einige zeit gebraucht um sich
auch den weg auszuarbeiten wie man das
schaffen will und eine möglichkeit ist
zum beispiel dass man natürlich
diejenigen die vom strukturwandel
besonders betroffen sind zb durch diesen
justice transition fand also durch den
fonds der auch diesen strukturwandel
begleitet dass man sie unterstützt und
die kommissionspräsidenten oder die
kommission hat jetzt erfreulicherweise
auch in dänemark wiederaufbau führung
sehr dafür gesorgt dass diese
transformations- mittel auch noch einmal
gestärkt worden und ich hoffe dass das
dann ein zusätzlicher anreiz ist um eben
auch diese klimaneutralität 2050 für
alle mitgliedstaaten der europäischen
union zu fahren kann ein sehr
erfolgreiches instrument zum klimaschutz
voranzubringen ist der emissionshandel
gerade im bereich industrie und energie
zeigt sich ja dass wir hier auch den co2
ausstoß nachhaltig reduzieren können wir
führen den emissionshandel jetzt auch
für die sektoren wärme und verkehr in
deutschland ein
was können sie dazu beitragen dass wir
auf europäischer ebene auch die anderen
staaten dazu motivieren in diesen
sektoren den emissionshandel auch mit
einzuführen in ganz europa ja es wichtig
ist dass wir immer wieder deutlich
machen dass wir für eine geraume zeit
zwei handelssysteme brauchen dass wir
jetzt also nicht den emissionshandel für
die industrie sofort mit dem verkehrs
und wärme emissionen
mandl verschmelzen können da gibt es
manchmal sorgen dann wären die preise
als dann wären die vermeidungskosten in
verkehr zu gering das produkt an sich zu
lasten der industrie auswirken das
dürfen wir nicht tun wir setzen uns
dafür ein die kommissionspräsidentin hat
sympathie erkennen lassen sie will das
thema aber erst im ersten halbjahr 2021
glaube ich angehen vorher werden wir
jetzt noch was anderes machen müssen
nämlich die veränderten im sich im blick
auf die neutralität klimaneutralität
2050 2030 ziele neu zu verhandeln und
dann dieses burden sharing also die
lastenaufteilung zwischen den
mitgliedstaaten neu zu bestimmen das
wird wahrscheinlich in die deutsche
ratspräsidentschaft fallen und das wird
ein ziemlich harter brocken werden
die fragesteller kollege klaus ernst die
linke herr präsident frau kanzlerin
haben ja nun die rettung der lufthansa
eigentlich eine richtige und auch
durchaus akzeptable sache die auch hier
unterstützt haben nur die auflagen die
sie gefunden haben die beschäftigung die
scheinen deutlich zu dürftig ist ist ja
nun so dass 9 milliarden fließen und
gleichzeitig die zahl der beschäftigten
reduziert werden sollen meine erste
frage warum haben sie nicht die die die
rettung dieses konzerns zumindest auf
die an die auflage gebunden dass sich
die bieten betriebsrat oder mit der
gewerkschaft einigen müssen über den
beschäftigungsabbau denn das hätte die
von ihnen oft sehr gelobte und
befürwortete tarifautonomie in diesen
fragen gestärkt und zweitens warum ist
es ihnen nicht gelungen zum beispiel
wenigstens hinzukriegen dass der
aufsichtsrat dieses unternehmens auch
von seiten der regierung gesetzt wird
von seiten der administration von uns
nun darf in sich lufthansa selbst
aussuchen den eigenen kontrolleur
erscheint mir etwas setzen
also ich will man daran erinnern dass
die lufthansa ein
sehr anerkanntes globales global
aufgestelltes unternehmen vor der korona
pandemie war und völlig unverschuldet in
eine lage kommen ist nämlich durch die
pandemie die wirklich nun dramatische
einbußen wenn man das so überhaupt damit
schon ausreichend beschreibt hinzunehmen
hat wir wollen dass sie wird lufthansa
wieder wirtschaftlich global agieren
kann
dafür haben wir die voraussetzung
gegeben wir glauben aber nicht dass in
dem der staat den aufsichtsrat stellt
und wir bestimmen wie viel in der zeit
nach der korona pandemie geflogen wird
und damit auch die zahl der
beschäftigten ist dass wir damit der
lufthansa einen gefallen tun
das ist halt der unterschied zwischen
uns und ihren auffassungen das ist so
und das manifestiert sich jetzt auch am
beispiel lufthansa für diese haltung
kann ja durchaus verständnis entwickeln
nur die frage ist wenn jetzt der der
kontrolleur bestimmt wird von dem der
ihn kontrolliert also wenn praktisch die
luft an seinen aufsichtsrat bestellt der
ihn kontrollieren soll
sie bestellt selben kontrolleur glauben
sie nicht dass es unter solchen
voraussetzungen eher dazu kommt das ist
egal was der vorstand macht seinem
abwinken kommt ich war selber in ihren
aufsichtsräten den sagen wir so offen
dass er die dass ihr die aufsichtsräte
die nicht mit dem unternehmen zusammen
hängen dass die waren die dann
tatsächlich die kritischen wir haben ja
für die beschäftigung sinnvoller
wir haben ja jetzt nicht die mehrheit an
der lufthansa erworben aus guten gründen
sondern wir haben uns das ja sehr genau
überlegt in welchem maße wir einsteigen
und in diesem maße sprechen wir
natürlich auch mit aber über personen
unseres vertrauens und nicht über den
staat und die idee dass der
lufthansa-vorstandsvorsitzende einfach
mal den aufsichtsrat aussucht die das
wissen sie ja auch dass wir anderes
zusammengesetzte aufsichtsräte haben als
dass die vorstände die aufsichtsräte
bestimmen so und das wird aus einer
mixtur gemacht sie finden da ist zu
wenig staatseinfluss wir finden dass
genau das richtige getan worden das
unterscheidet uns und wir wollen dass
die lufthansa nicht verlernt
wirtschaftlich zu handeln
global ziemlich umkämpften umfeld damit
sie weiter ein starkes unternehmen ist
das aus deutschland kommen ostendorff
bündnis 90/die grünen stellt die nächste
frage
jetzt frau bundeskanzlerin sie äußerten
am 13 mai hier ihre unzufriedenheit mit
den zuständen in den großstädten
wir haben in den letzten wochen viel
dazu erfahren ich will denen sagen
persönlich ich bin seit 52 jahren bauer
habe vor 45 jahren für einige jahre in
einen großschlachthof gearbeitet was hat
sich verändert es ist immer schlimmer
geworden es war damals unsäglich und
heute ist es noch unsäglicher die
bedingungen der menschen dort sind nie
besser geworden sie sind immer
schlechter geworden was konkret neben
dem beschreiben der zustände oder was
soll ich verstehen als mensch der recht
und gesetz gelernt hat dass bauernjunge
wenn man ministerpräsident mir gestern
erklärt die kooperation sei zu ende
zwischen schlachthaus und
landesregierung jetzt würde recht und
gesetz gelten ich hatte gedacht es gilt
es schon immer aber das will ich jetzt
gar nicht mit ihnen diskutieren sondern
meine frage geht dahin die
bundesministerinnen die zuständige hat
erklärt wir wollen die große
schlachthöfe dezentralisieren wie sieht
genauer fahrplan dazu aus ist das
abgestimmt was kann ich darunter
verstehen wir werden die abläufe sein
dass jetzt endlich zur humanen
bedingungen für die menschen für die
tiere und für die bauern und bäuerinnen
die dahin liefern kommen also recht und
gesetz galt und gilt immer das habe ich
als pastorentochter auch gelernt konnte
es die ersten 43 35 jahre meines lebens
noch nicht ganz so am eigenen leib
erfahren umso wichtiger ist dass es mir
dass es heute so ist zweitens wir werden
die verträge für diese branche
abschaffen weil sie so ausgenutzt wurden
in sub sub sub sub unternehmen das das
nicht verantwortbar ist
drittens werden damit vielleicht die
kosten steigen
ich nehme das an das ist aber auch in
ordnung so und dann wird es auch wieder
bessere wettbewerbsbedingungen geben
dass sich auch kleinere schlachthöfe
vielleicht bilden können und das wäre zu
erstreben denn wir haben es ja bei
molkereien werden special acht hilfen
die konzentration im lebensmittelbereich
dazu die abnahme konzentration ist für
die bauern ein großes problem leider
noch die zustände aber auch in
schlachthöfen die von bauern sozusagen
mitgestaltet werden nicht immer so ideal
dass man
jetzt sagen würde das ist schon das
vorbild weil der druck einfach so da
sind weil die anderen preisträger sind
das weiß ich schon mit deshalb muss
damals verändert werden nachfrage
kollegen ja meine nachfolge geht dahin
wir haben am freitag eine debatte über
das papier was von ex bundesminister
jochen borchert und seiner kommission
erarbeitet worden ist zum umbau der
tierhaltung ein papier was weite teile
der gesellschaftlichen gruppen beteiligt
hat wo viele mitgearbeitet haben wie ich
es nicht kenne mich nicht erinnern kann
dass es möglich war
zwischen landschaftsverbänden umwelt und
tierschutzverbänden so breit aufgestellt
zu gemeinsamen vereinbarungen zu kommen
wenn wir das jetzt beschließen am
freitag wie werden sie konkret es
unterstützen dass die bemühungen der
erzeugerin unserer zeuge der bauern und
bäuerinnen das ja da ist man spürte es
die bauern und bäuerinnen sind bereit um
zu bauen sie sind bereit den weg zu
gehen wie bringen sie als
bundeskanzlerin hier verlässlichkeit
rein möglicherweise über die tierwohl
abgabe die bei jochen borchert hier
vorschlägt
was geben sie da wie ist da ihr weg aber
wie wollen sie auch denjenigen denen es
dann möglicherweise noch etwas schwerer
fällt gutes fleisch zu kaufen wie werden
sie denen den sozialen ausgleich
ermöglichen was werden wir dort zu
erwarten haben wird es bei hartz4 wird
es bei mindestlohn nachbesserungen geben
also die bestimmung von hartz 4 sätzen
der inhalte tja auch meinen ganzen
warenkorb und dazu gehören natürlich
auch lebensmittel dazu gehört auch
fleisch wenn ich vielleicht also teurer
würde dann würde sich das sicherlich
auch in der berechnung des
hartz-iv-satzes niederschlagen aber
fangen wir mal andersherum an wir haben
jetzt 300 millionen im
konjunkturprogramm zur verfügung
gestellt damit relativ schnell stall
umbau statt drinnen kann und ich finde
es auch ganz wichtig dass wir diesen
prozess so gestalten dass nicht zum
schluss wir keine bauern mehr haben in
deutschland die tiere halten davon haben
wir auch dann nichts gewonnen
das heißt also ich freue mich auch dass
es vielleicht
ganz vorsichtig eine chance gibt dass im
bundesrat das kastenstand urteil jetzt
mal umgesetzt wird und dass dieser
umbauprozess auch wirklich in gang
kommen kann
wir wissen alle dass das mehrere jahre
dauern wird dass es nicht von heute auf
morgen zu machen aber wir müssen beim
tierwohl unbedingt etwas tun und ich
glaube wenn wir offen denjenigen der auf
der bevölkerung gegenüber treten und
sagen wir wollen tierhaltung in
deutschland wir wollen sie aber zu
vernünftigen bedingungen wir haben mit
dieser borchert kommission gezeigt dass
mehr gemeinsam ist möglich ist als wir
dachten und jetzt gehen wir diesen weg
mal an ohne schaum vorm mund und nehmen
die bauern mit und sie haben recht viele
bauern sind da auch schon ein stück
weiter dann haben wir mal was
wesentliches geschafft sind aber längst
noch nicht an dem punkt wo wir sein
müssten dass sozusagen aus dem ausland
aus dänemark zum beispiel viele rinder
oder schweine hier in deutschland
geschlachtet werden weil es hier so
schön billig ist und man es bei sich zu
hause nicht machen kann das halte ich
nicht für den erstrebenswerten vorgang
sondern wir müssen das zeigt nur dass
wir an dieser stelle auch preis nicht
was tun müssen und dann wird muss man
auf der sozialen seite schauen dass das
nicht menschen vom fleisch essen
ausschließen das ist okay aber das kann
nicht der punkt sein das fleisch bildnis
billig ist und tiere möglichst leiden
damit es möglichst sozialverträglich ist
das ist ja genau das schwierige
wirtschaft und soziales
zusammenzubringen damit beende ich die
regierungsbefragung angeblich mit
bundeskanzlerin füge die guten wünsche
vermute des ganzen hauses für die heute
beginnende rats präsidentschaft an und
uwe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 3
[Applaus]
so